[Musique]
rentrée scolaire perturbé les écoles de
chambourcy sont fermés pour au moins une
semaine après la découverte de 13,4 du
variant sud africain du corry 19 une
grande campagne de dépistage a été
organisée dans le gymnase de la ville
les tests salivaires seront également
déployés dans les écoles primaires des
hippies clap de fin pour les soldes
d'hiver un bilan plutôt positif au
centre juan les chaînes des
clayes-sous-bois qui a pu rester ouverts
grâce à ces espaces à l'extérieur
puisque l'on parle commerce le
département des yvelines soutient les
commerçants de chevreuse en leur
attribuant une aide d'urgence
au total ce sont 48 1500 euros qui ont
été refinancés par le département pour
la commune le port du masque est
dorénavant obligatoire partout dans les
yvelines décision prise par le préfet
pour freiner l'épidémie de kobe 19
il est aussi interdit de consommer de
l'alcool sur la voie publique
on en sait davantage sur le quartier des
savoirs qui sera sorti de terre d'ici
2030 à guyancourt situés sur les
anciennes friches de thales ce nouveau
quartier accueillera la ligne 18 la
future gare et environ 2000 logements et
commerces
le plan de restructuration des collèges
a été dévoilé par le département 15
établissements devraient être construits
d'ici 2025 pour un coût total de 525
millions d'euros
[Musique]
comment